Hey everyone, I’m Emily here for a DNews
short.
The National Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
just released the first images from GOES-16,
their newest weather satellite orbiting the
planet, and they are GORGEOUS.
The Advanced Baseline Imager instrument, a
specialized camera onboard GOES-16, captured
this picture of the Americas and the surrounding
oceans.
Look at this beautiful planet we live on!
The GOES-16, which orbits 22,300 miles above
Earth, helps NOAA observe global weather and
will lead to better solar and space weather
models, and more accurate, life-saving forecasts
here on Earth.
Here you can see South America on the left
and off to the right is Africa.
The Saharan Dust Layer is pretty visible over
Africa, which is more important than you may
think.
Saharan dust in the atmosphere helps reduce
the intensity of tropical storms when it makes
its way over to the tropics.
And with clearer, more accurate images, scientists
can better predict the severity of those storms!
You can see here what makes this satellite
so special.
The GOES-16 can take color images at four
times the resolution of the existing GOES
satellites.
It also has 16 spectral channels — three-times
the amount of previous GOES satellites — which
show different wavelengths of light.
Some of these channels were combined to get
color images like the one you just saw.
The satellite can help forecasters differentiate
clouds from smoke and volcanic ash.
This image shows part of Mexico and Central
America.
Most of the area is pretty free of cloud coverage
but zoom in and you can see smoke from a massive
fire near the coast in southern Mexico.
The GOES-16 is also faster, providing an image
of an area the size of the United States every
five minutes!
NOAA is pretty excited, calling it “the
most sophisticated technology ever flown in
space to predict severe weather on Earth.”
So hopefully now I’ll be able to actually
trust the weather forecast on my phone!
Satellites like GOES-16 are awesome, but space
weather can interfere with them.
Did you know that?
Find out more in this video here.
Do you have any other weather-related questions?
Let us know in the comments, please subscribe
and come back everyday for DNews.